from the legendary pele to west
germany's gab mula
and more unsavory moments they're all
part of the world of soccer history
according to helmand axel
the argentinian cartoonist lives in
germany and is famed for his
reinventions of iconic photographs from
past tournaments
i have the luxury of making a living
from a personal passion
i love soccer and i love drawing
as a young boy in buenos aires i used to
play five aside
my friends would call and ask if i was
coming out
yeah i'd say i'll be right there
hellman exhale has published a complete
compendium of world cup history it
includes argentina versus uruguay in the
inaugural final in 1930
mario kempis scoring two in 1978 and
reunited germany's triumph in 1990.
south africa in 2010 was remembered as
much for the overpowering noise off the
pitch as for spain overpowering
opponents on it
every world cup has its key moments the
miracle of burn for germany
the hand of god
uses a variety of sources for his
caricatures in the case of arsenal and
germany midfielder mesut ozil a range of
photos plus videos
are my two favorites
those two offer
the artist takes us through the
evolution of ozil the obvious starting
point for this portrait are his
distinctive big eyes
all in all ideal for a cartoon
cartoons have been featured in a number
of magazines he started out working for
argentinian and brazilian publications
but his biggest clients these days are
british fanzine 442 and germany's
youth-oriented bravo sport
there are various kinds of cartoons not
just your classic portraits
i draw crucial
i do little cartoons for the german
magazine with funny endings
they're made
has passed on those soccer crazy jeans
to his kids who miss no opportunity for
a kickabout
dad's silky skills are not limited to
the pen so what about the upcoming world
cup on a personal level
i'll be watching with my family which is
not as harmless as it sounds
my wife is german
plus my father-in-law over there
imagine his own dream team he can draw
it with pele maradona zidane and
beckenbauer in the lineup a team
difficult to imagine being beaten on
paper
he also has a dream scenario for the
final
argentinian goal-getter leonel messi
wizards his way through the german ranks
in the final minute of extra time
finishing off with a cool back heel
a lot of argentinians want to see an
argentina brazil fight
i think it would be pretty cruel for
argentina to become champions in brazil
whether his cartoon of argentina
becoming world champions for the third
time remains just a dream or ends up
gracing the cover of a magazine will not
be resolved until after the final on
july 13th